Barack Obama is returning to politics
Barack Obama and former attorney General
Eric Holder are teaming up to fight what
is a fundamental but often overlooked
problem with American politics we've
done interviews about it we've got an
upcoming long-form piece about it the
issue is gerrymandering and this is
already drawing out the conspiracy
theorists including Alex Jones and the
people over at Infowars I'll tell you
about that in a second most presidents
tend to lay pretty low after they leave
the White House George W Bush because of
the disaster that his presidency was has
been relegated to painting pictures
while taking baths at his house that is
not going to be at least not immediately
what Barack Obama is going to do two
months after leaving office President
Obama is getting involved with a
Democratic Party organization committed
to combating Republican gerrymandering
throughout the United States he is
working with none other than the
National Democratic redistricting
committee which is chaired by former
attorney General Eric Holder Holder said
to Politico during an interview quote
it's coming he's coming and he's ready
to roll this is really a battle for
democracy gerrymandering congressional
districts and state legislative
districts have given Republicans a huge
leg up since 2011 when the United States
last redrew district lines it was
widespread Republican control and this
is a big factor in why Congress is
currently controlled by the Republican
Party and what the NDRC wants to do is
win back seats in state legislative
houses and in the House of
Representatives by demanding fairer
district line-drawing and we're going to
have a whole piece about this pad
referendums can be a factor here state
legislators have control of
redistricting they're the ones who stand
to benefit from gerrymandering President
Obama will also be working with the
Democratic legislative Campaign
Committee which supports Democratic
candidates and also fights back against
Republican gerrymandering are you
excited about this Obama returning to
politics I am excited about him
returning to politics my take on the
whole gerrymandering thing
Oh is Democrats can do the exact same
thing and they have but only in a
minority of states if you look at
Illinois Massachusetts Maryland those
states are really badly gerrymandered
and by Democrats and I think that's bad
when they do it too I think maybe we
should be moving towards having a
nonpartisan Commission yeah control of
this but I can see Barack Obama and Eric
Holder they're Democrats they're going
to try to win back the seats for their
own party there's sort of two arguments
one is the entire thing should just go
over to a fairer system period the
counter would be well things are so
heavily skewed in Republicans favor that
we can simultaneously vote to change the
system to one that is more neutral but
until that happens we should be trying
to win seats back so that we can push
the push things back in our favor the
quote I read to you about how President
Obama is ready this has sent the
conspiracy theorists including Alex
Jones and Infowars into a tizzy
check out the screenshot Holder
foretells the return of Obama he's
coming and he's ready to roll the rules
don't really apply to Obama now do they
they're acting like this is some kind of
foretelling of an attempt by Obama to
seize back power or something I mean
it's all just so hyperbolic I mentioned
this on a recent livestream I've been
checking out a few minutes of Alex Jones
daily and the politics obviously are
bonkers but the Schilling for these
bogus pseudo health products is really
the most disturbing aspect of the show
he's got these male vitality pills now
he sells female vitality pills and he
has it's like the female news people are
talking about just they just don't feel
quite right when they don't take their
female vitality so they take these pills
in the morning and then they're quote
ready to go it's stunning shilling for
pseudoscience there was even an ad there
on the screenshot that we showed maybe
you'll put it up oh yeah back up oh yeah
activate your body's natural defenses
with something called my cozy ex uh yeah
I don't even know what to say would you
ever buy stuff like that no I'm also
amazed that you're watching Alex Jones
it makes you wonder how many of the
people that are watching them are
actually not on board with what he says
I actually caught a few minutes of the
Alex Jones YouTube livestream the other
day and as a total goof like I
never comment anywhere but I commented
in the chat out of curiosity how many
people are here watching this just as a
goof purely for entertainment nobody
responded but it didn't got to be a lot
of people that watch it as a goof that
would be a great reddit post I would
imagine yes I think that would be a
discussion for a reddit discussion forum